hello everyone so welcome to this
session and um
my name is lauren rusla i'm the
moderator for this session i'm very
excited to be here
with me today is jacob schreiber
who is a postdoctoral researcher at
stanford university where he develops
machine learning based tools to tackle
problems in genomics he is also the
developer of a cornucopia of open source
tools in python including pom grenade
which implements flexible probabilistic
modeling and apricot which implements
submodular optimization for data subset
selection
and previously he was also a core
developer for scikit-learn and today he
will be talking about yeah apricot
support layer optimization for
minimizing redundancy in massive data
sets
so um i hope you all enjoy the talk and
over to you jacob
great thank you for the introduction uh
as florian said i'm jacob schreiber i'm
a postdoctoral researcher working on
machine learning and computational
biology at stanford today i'm going to
be talking about this package apricot
that i wrote
that aims to try to minimize the
redundancy that exists in massive data
sets one of my motivations for creating
this package is because data sets are
beginning increasingly large over time
back in the good old days of 1936 they
collected someone collected this data
set that had four measurements of 150
different iris flowers this was great
because it was used as a toy data set
for a long time because most statistical
and machine learning methods could be
run almost instantaneously on it so
you're able to develop and iterate very
quickly
then the computer vision community
started to adopt this mnist data set
which had uh tens of thousands of
different images of handwritten digits
each with hundreds of different features
each feature being a pixel
so
methods weren't quite as fast uh methods
were still fairly fast on eminence but
they weren't instantaneous like they
were on irs
even later in the image that data set
came out which had over 10 million
different images with 50 over 50 000
pixels per image so these were high
resolution images tons of uh examples
and you started to need specialized
hardware in order to do computation even
today people to trade most modern
methods you need at least one gpu you
generally need clusters of gpus in order
to get this done in any reasonable
amount of time
progress didn't end there either that
data sets have been getting increasingly
large you now have data sets with
billions of images you have compendia of
video or genomics data or health records
we are inundated with massive data sets
now and this is good because the more
data we have the more we're able to
train sophisticated machine learning
models and evaluate them robustly to
make sure that they work in a real world
setting
however
as data sets increase in size they
generally also increase in redundancy
two researchers found that when they
looked at c410 and c400 which are some
toy datasets used in the computer vision
community that there were many examples
that were very similar to each other
there are either slight rotations of the
same idea or slight recolorations of the
the same image
worse there were some that were near
duplicates they weren't exactly
perceptually the same but they were
basically slight recolorings of uh the
same type
basically the same object the same angle
even worse than that there were some
exact duplicates in these data sets
when these types of redundant examples
exist in training data they can waste
computational time because your model is
exposed to them but it doesn't there's
no new information in them for the model
to gain
when they exist in uh across across the
train test split there are some
uh you can get overly optimistic
estimate to performance there's some
philosophical things about how to
construct a trained test split that i'm
not going to get into right now but
certainly within the context of
uh but certainly within the context of
um
training data that having redundant
examples can be incredibly wasteful
so we get to this idea of submodular
optimization some module optimization is
to submodular set functions as convex
optimization is to convex functions
basically a set function is a function
that takes in a set of items and outputs
a scalar
a set function is submodular if it obeys
this diminishing returns property and i
swear there are only two slides with
like math on them and this is the first
of those slides
the gist here is that a set function is
submodular if it obeys this diminishing
returns property which basically says
that some held out item v the gain of
adding that held out item v to a set x
is greater than adding that uh item v to
some set y when x is a subset of y
basically as x increases in size the
benefit of adding v decreases
so if that doesn't quite make sense i
have some examples that will hopefully
clarify things in the uh in the next few
slides
something i really like about sub-module
optimization though is that you can be
super creative in terms of the types of
functions that you use these functions
don't need to be continuous or
differentiable like they do in the
convex setting you can include things
like if statements for loops all types
of crazy things as long as they obey
this diminishing returns property
and a quick note on optimization that
optimizing a submodular set function
basically finding the optimal subset of
items according to it uh is np-hard but
this is really cool theoretical results
showing that if you use the greedy
algorithm where you find one item at a
time you can get within a constant
factor approximation approximation of
the up optimal subset this is an
incredibly rare result and in practice
you generally get almost the optimal
subset anyway when you use the greedy
algorithm so i thought i just mentioned
that in the same way that people use
convex optimization to optimize
non-convex models people use the greedy
algorithm to optimize submodular set
functions
so
you know that's a lot of theory and
details now let's go into a you know
real world example that i'm sure you're
going to encounter imagine you just
finished watching the hit tv show gossip
girl and you were asked by a friend to
summarize the show using only two of the
characters
a plausible situation i know you might
initially be inclined to choose blair
and serena because of course blair is
the best character and serena is her
bestie
but if you step back you might think
okay well these two storylines are very
intertwined with each other so i don't
necessarily want to choose both of these
because we're going to be missing huge
gaps of the gossip girl storyline so you
having just attended a submodular
optimization
talk realized that you can craft a
submodular function that takes in a set
of characters and returns the number of
scenes that they appear in
basically what you do is you craft this
function that goes through each scene
and set basically assigns a one if any
of the fun if any of the characters in
this set appear in it otherwise zero
now this isn't exactly you know it's an
approximate approximation of how
important each character is the
storyline but since the gossip girl
storyline is so tight-knit and has no
nonsense in that it's a pretty good
approximation
so
imagine that you take the character dan
and you put it through this function you
might get something like they appear in
10 scenes in some particular episode
then you go through and you put blair in
you see if they appear in 17 scenes
which makes sense because blair is the
best character
but
you'll notice that if you put both dan
and blair into this function you only
get 22 instead of 27 this is because
they appear in some scenes together
finally if you then add jenny to this
function you'll notice that the benefit
is very marginal and this is because
jenny's role in the show is either uh to
act as a worse version of dan or as a
worse version of blair but this serves
to demonstrate what the diminishing
returns property is that basically the
more characters you add to your set the
less the benefit of adding bl of adding
jenny would be that either they are in
that either some character you add is in
scenes with jenny that the other
characters aren't in in which case the
benefit of adding jenny goes down or
they're not in which case the benefit
stays the same but the benefit would
never go up and so that's the key idea
behind sub-modular functions
so
now that we've identified a function
that we could use uh and seen what the
diminishing returns property is how do
we actually optimize this
i'm going to demonstrate this using uh
just a general class of functions called
the feature-based functions the one we
described is a feature-based function
this is a general class of submodular
functions
imagine that you have some data set
where each row is an example and each
column is a feature what you would do
because this is a greedy algorithm is
you would start with the first example
and you would try to measure the
function value given it
well you take that
the first thing that you do in this
function is you sum down the columns of
all of the selected examples well you
haven't selected anything yet and so the
sum is just going to be the future
values for that first example
then you apply fee which is any type of
concave function generally i use square
root because it's fast but it's any
function that is estab that is uh has a
diminishing returns aspect to it
so you apply that function and then you
sum along the resulting vector and you
get some value and that is the value of
you know the set that you've put in
now let's say you scan through all the
items in this data set and you've
determined that the first item is the
best one and you're trying to determine
the second item to add and you're
considering this purple one well now you
you do your sum as normal which are
going to be the sum of the purple
feature values and the orange feature
values note here that there are two
purple feature values that have the same
uh they have the same value uh this
feature here where orange also has a
high feature value and this one here
where orange has a low feature value
when you apply your uh your function
with diminishing returns what you'll
notice is that the benefit of adding the
purple example to this feature that
already had a lot of it a lot observed
is small but the same feature value is
much higher when you haven't observed
the feature this gives these functions a
property where it's trying to choose
examples where you were seeing features
that you didn't see in previous examples
so this is good when your features
represent different quantity qualities
of the data
and the higher value corresponds to
having more of that quality so this
works for things like set functions or
when you have things like word counts or
if you have posterior probabilities or
labels or like a kernel matrix or
something like that it's not going to
work well for things like xy coordinates
so here you might get some you know
additional value and then you choose the
example with the highest gain given the
first feature that you the first example
that you already saw now like all good
talks let's return to gossip girl
imagine
uh so in this um
in this show as you all know there are
these text message blasts that are set
out by this character known as gossip
girl just in time to stir up trouble
amongst all the main characters the
first one in the show reads like this
spotted lonely boy can't believe the
love of his life was returned if only
she knew who he was but everyone knows
serena and everyone is talking wonder
what blair waldorf thinks sir they're
bffs but we always thought their
boyfriend nate had a thing for serena
perfect this is exactly what my high
school experience was like it just
brings me back to those times
so
the idea here is that you go you might
if you have a friend that says well so
me uh i want to see how gossip girl
talks about each one of the characters
so show me a set of blasts that talks
about as many of the characters as
possible
what you could do is you could go
through all the blasts each one of the
blasts is a different row and code them
based on whether or not they mention a
particular character in the cell and you
might get something that looks like this
where the orange indicates that a
character is mentioned in a blast and
the gray means that they are not
if you take a submodular set function
which is just you know summing over the
number of characters that uh you see
the first blast that you pull out might
look something like this
not so fast you're not graduating until
i give you my diplomas mine or labels
and label stick nate archibald something
i'm not going to repeat
dan humphrey the ultimate insider chuck
bass coward blair waldorf weakling and
as for serena vanderwooden after today
you are officially irrelevant
congratulations everyone you deserve it
great perfect amazing this is how i wish
everyone talked all the time
but you'll notice here that the gist is
that it has chosen a blast that mentions
as many characters as possible because
it's trying to optimize seeing as
high feature values and as many of the
features as possible
correspondingly the next one is poor
vanessa even cinderella was given the
courtesy of a stealth getaway then again
what's a trio of lovely stepsisters
compared to jenny humphrey looks like it
might turn into unhappily after everyone
after ever for everyone
you'll notice here that what's happening
is that it's choosing a blast that
mentions characters that were not
mentioned in the first last
and so this is how these types of
feature-based functions generally
proceed that they choose a first example
that is has as high feature values and
as many features as possible and then
iteratively choose subsequent examples
that have high feature values and
features that were not observed before
in contrast to feature-based functions
another broad class of some modular
functions or the graph based functions
these ones don't operate on examples you
know that have featurization but rather
they take in a graph like a network or
you know like a social network or an
interaction network transit or something
like that
facility location is probably the most
famous graph based uh function and you
know actually the most widely used
submodular function that exists it's
literally used to locate facilities thus
the name you can also think about it
like a greedy version of the k-meat wage
algorithm or it's also known as the
k-means plus plus initialization
the idea here is that you want to choose
centroids that are very similar to
uh to very simple that are very similar
to examples that are not well
represented by the already existing
centroids
so
to give you an example um i was sitting
in an airport one day and i had the
delightful gift of having my flight
delayed by several hours and as a tech
worker with no understanding of how a
domain works i thought i was perfectly
suited to solve this optimization
problem so i thought why don't i just
download a whole bunch of data from open
flights and try to figure out where
airlines should place their hubs in
order to make my life more convenient so
here are all the airports that are
located in the united states according
to open flights and when you connect
them you see a bunch of hubs starting to
emerge this is by no means all of the
flights that occur in the united states
these are just the ones that were in the
open flight database at the time that i
um
downloaded them
if you take the number of airports if
you take the airports that have the most
number of flights
uh total the airport service a total
number of 256 unique routes and they
include some of the airports you'd
expect like atlanta is definitely going
to be a hub chicago is probably going to
be a hub denver hub these are classic
hubs that almost every airline has
but
if you represent these airport if you
represent this as a graph where all of
the nodes represent airports and all the
edges or connections between those
airports you can use facility location
in order to choose airports that service
more unique routes
and what you get is this you'll notice
that bethel airport in alaska is chosen
because it services a lot of airports in
rural alaska however the real reason
that there's one that this is uh you
know a more correct placement of hubs is
because include seattle which is my home
town at the time so because it included
my home that of course it had to be
correct
but it also services 270 unique house
instead of 256.
so you can imagine how someone would
quite literally use facility location in
order to try to locate where they placed
new facilities because it doesn't
involve
since you use a greedy algorithm to
optimize it it doesn't involve changing
the location of any previous facilities
just choosing new facilities that are
good for under currently
underrepresented uh places
but the main purpose of apricot isn't
just to implement some module
optimization generally it's to work in
the context of its machine learning so
let's return the two toy data sets used
in machine learning contacts a lot the
mnist data sets i talked about before in
fashion mnist which is a similar type of
thing except it includes articles of
clothing rather than numbers
if we run facility locate here each of
these data sets that are projected into
umap space needs the dots as an example
in the training set if what we do is we
run submodular optimization on uh these
data sets you'll notice that on mnist
our facility location function pulls out
basically each of the ten digits except
for five five is the worst digit anyway
so it doesn't really matter that it
doesn't pull that one out but this
doesn't have any concept of labels it
doesn't know what a label is at all what
labels are for these at all simply by
trying to maximize the diversity of the
chosen examples you know minimize the
redundancy it ends up choosing examples
that are you know across
the labor space and you can see it does
something similar for
articles of clothing that it doesn't
ignore these kind of islands that are
far away from the other ones it makes
sure that it chooses all of them and you
can see that's fairly representative of
the entire space
but the real test is what happens when
we train machine learning models on it
if what we do is we choose only a subset
of our data and train a logistic
regression model on these tasks how well
does it perform so you can see here on
the x-axis what happens when we choose a
certain number of examples
when we choose a certain number of
examples using either random selection
or when we use facility location on the
mnist data set we see great results but
using only 200 examples we see better
results than when we use random
selection uh with 2 000 examples this is
great we can use one tenth of the data
and achieve even better results not only
that but in this case we could probably
even visualize all of that and just take
a look manually at what our data looks
like
basically using some modular
optimization to create a summary that a
human could interpret
on fast and eminence it seems like we
are consistently outperforming the
median performance of
um of using random selection but that
we're not seeing results that are as
good as um
that are not as good as on the normal
mnist data set
and so that brings me to a point that
it's super important to use the right
featurization to use the right
submodular function with the type of
data that you're using in the same way
that you wouldn't want to just use like
a completely dense network on a high
resolution image you don't want to use
the wrong type of sub-module
optimization on data there's no function
that works on all types of data so you
want to make sure that you choose a
function that truly represents what's
going on in the underlying type of data
feature-based functions work well like i
said before when each one of the
features corresponds to some notion of
quality of the data and the higher value
means having more of that quality so you
might need to transform your data a
little bit in order to get it to work
but then the scale incredibly well
in contrast graph-based functions
require similarities between pairs of
items and so they are more general
purpose that they they don't have any
constraints on what the features need to
mean that the similarities are
calculated from but they do require
quadratic memory with respect they need
to store the entire graph in memory so
they require amount of memory requires
the number of edges
so how can we speed that up because if
you have a giant data set and you want
to run facility location it's going to
suck if you just can't do that because
it doesn't fit in memory
well the first thing you can do is use
sparse data formats if your data is
sparse like you have a whole bunch of
zeros and you want to run a feature
based function on it or you have a
sparse graph you can just use that in
apricot that you only need
amount of memory proportional you need
only amount of memory and compute for
personal to the number of non-zero
entries in your data and so if you're
working with the sparse data the bigger
it is the bigger the speed up that you
can see here on the left hand side we
have
the amount of time it takes working in a
dense format versus a sparse format for
something that's only one percent
non-zeros you see that not only does
you know the does not only does the
amount of time non-increase is fast but
the speed up improves as you have more
data as you get a bigger and bigger data
set the benefit increases
a second thing you can do is use these
algorithms developed for streaming
submodular optimization this is the
setting where you only see each example
once and you need to know whether or not
you want to keep it in your
representative subset
um it's a bit complicated so i'm not
going to go into the theory of how this
works but there's just that there's this
parameter epsilon which is inversely
related to the coarseness basically the
smaller epsilon is the the more
the sorry
normally proportional where the smaller
that epsilon is the more uh fine-grained
your distinction can be unfortunately
even in the finest grain setting you
don't perform as well as if you had all
of your data in memory but you perform
significantly better that you just take
randomly chosen examples which is the
gray line on the bottom
so the benefit is that you only do one
pass through your entire data set and
now you have your uh function
so what's in apricot we have a variety
of built-in submodular functions as well
as optimization algorithms the goal is
to be like pytor to tensorflow where
even though we have some of these
components built in that you're able to
plug and play them however you want uh
it's not like scikit-learn with each out
you know with linear regression there's
a few different optimizers built into it
that you can only use that you can use
any optimizer on any function and vice
versa
we have several speed optimizations that
aren't talked about here including
several algorithmic tricks a number
based implementation that speeds up
things a ton and it provides
multi-threaded parallelism uh k n
approximations of dense similarity
matrix that even if you have a dense
similarity matrix you can still get a
sparse approximation of it for faster
speed
approximate 3d optimizers and more
you can also write your own
it's really easy to write your own
optimizer or to write your own somewhat
of the function and to optimize it like
i said these things can have all types
of things like if statements etc all
types of crazy stuff in them and you can
just plug and play them we have a bunch
of tutorials on the github for how you
can do this
then finally kind of an interesting
point is that because all of these work
on greedy algorithms you can start off
with the set of points that you want to
build off of if you say i need to have
this set of data when training my model
but i want to then choose points that
are representative you know that uh that
are minimally redundant with those set
you can easily put that into apricot and
get a nice uh
nice improvement there
so if you would like to see tutorials
and documentation of the code in general
you should go to the
github page if you want to see the paper
behind some of the decisions we made
when designing the package you should
read our gmail paper
on it
so thank you for your time
excellent thank you jacob
spot on really here i like it
um
are there any questions uh i think so
far i haven't seen anything
um maybe
have somebody now posting
um but
from from my side um i guess
a bit like naively asking um
so so what would be
like a
how to phrase that
if i if you think about it uh
in terms of
data selection as a primary use case for
for something i could use just uh the
next day for example that would be kind
of the the first thing that pops into my
head but what are maybe like some of the
kind of
second level use cases that i could
think about
yeah so the way i predominantly use
modular optimization is when
um
[Music]
is in the computational biology setting
the gist is that we don't have
um
the the gist is that in this setting
acquiring measurements is expensive and
so what we do is that we have a set of
we've performed a subset of measurements
already we train a machine learning
model in order to make predictions for
what everything should be and then we
run sub-module optimization on the
predictions in order to get a very
diverse set of what we expect to be able
to observe
and so having that first step of
training a predictive model and then the
second step of subsequently choosing
which elements to verify in order to get
a very you know
uh non-redundant set of measurements
given a limited budget is really
powerful in the computational biology
setting and really it's going to be
powerful in any setting where you have
sensors and measurements are expensive
i know that google does things like uh
if they want to and you know i've done
this personally where if you want to
create a highlight reel of photos
that with this doesn't involve machine
learning much at all but i guess you
extract feature representations using
some sort of pre-trained model and then
you run some module optimization in
order to be able to
filter out you know if you have a
thousand photos of your cat and a bunch
of different photos of you know your
vacations that you probably want to
photo you know one photo of your cat but
you don't want it to be 90 photos of
your cat you want to make sure that
you're
you know seeing that seeing that well
represented and move on to other parts
in your album space
excellent well thank you for for that
answer um
i don't see any more questions so i'm
left with um thanking you again for the
amazing talk i hope you enjoy the rest
of the conference
as well as all the attendees and
yeah well
have a nice for me it's night
afternoon or evening wherever you are
thank you have a great day